now what I want to do is I just want to
extend this and I think this is probably
where we're going to finish when I
mentioned before I'm just going to
scroll back right I mentioned before
we've got this idea of ratio Division
and then we said okay there's a start
Point there's an end point and then you
know in whatever ratio you want one to
one two to one three to two Etc that
gives you some point that divides up the
interval okay one of the things I didn't
say before though is that all of this is
one uh one species of ratio division
this is what we call internal Division
and the reason why it's called internal
division is exactly as the name suggests
you end up inside the interval right so
A's here B is here you end up somewhere
in between now
you might be able to guess from the name
right if there's such a thing as
internal division there is also such a
thing as
external division which is so weird to
me because as you as the name suggests
you end up outside right which is like
hold on but you're not are you even
dividing up the thing anymore like you
you end up somewhere on the outside so
let's actually draw this right I'm going
to give you an example
and um I'll I'll work this example for
you on on my screen I think that'll give
me enough space just there okay so
suppose I said to you all right we're
gonna do that same ratio one to two but
I'm going to do it externally
so this is um a b divided in the ratio
one to two externally okay this is a bit
wild but again just like with our
internal division uh treat the um
however they've named the interval so in
this case it's a b rather than b a you
start at the first point so in this case
it's a
and then instead of going toward the
other point instead of going to Ward B
to get outside I'm gonna go away from b
um I want to go away
one and then come back two
that's weird right okay let's let me
show you how this is going to work right
I'm going to go in the opposite
direction from B so I'm going to go away
from from B and I'm going to end up on
this spot over here this will be the P
that I get and the rate the reason I
know it's over there is because if I can
imagine going one
in that direction
and now to get back and end at B I'm now
going to go two hops that same length
can you see that
so that orange part is two and that
black part there is one it's so strange
you counter-intuitive okay now
um back in the day uh when Mrs Isles and
I when we did maths uh this was this was
in like just 2D a 2d version of this was
in corn geometry in the extension one
course and um there's two ways that you
can think about this
um number one and maybe you can actually
see it by the way I've drawn it
you can actually instead of thinking of
this as one to two externally you can
actually think of this as negative one
to two internally
um I I know this is gonna sound strange
but if you there's a formula for doing
this
um and you'll see it actually in the
textbook in the worked examples I'm
deliberately not showing you the formula
because
um you can learn the formula and just
get the answer right and still have no
idea what you're doing um I know that
for a fact because that's what I did in
year 12.
yeah
foreign
yeah it is um it's wild and you know I'm
just gonna say sometimes you will learn
a thing in in maths or in another
subject and you just kind of say oh you
know what I'm just going to memorize it
I'm just going to do it and I don't have
the understanding yet okay but but you
want to work toward it however for
something like this hopefully you can
see actually a better way to do this is
just to use some of our Vector thinking
in order to work out what this is so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to ask
us to go with the same a and the same B
in the in the example that we just
worked through and I'm going to ask us
to to think about how would we find a
new Point P that divides it one to two
externally so let me just redraw this
situation okay actually I'll again I'm
going to cheat and grab some of this
okay so same a same B
new page
okay here we go let's get rid of all
this stuff that we don't need
uh this is gonna be tricky do my best ah
no I've just a lot okay I'm just gonna
leave that there I think you'll be
satisfied okay now if this is where a
and b are I'll make it a bit smaller
okay
and remember we've kind of already
established at least very roughly right
where p is going to be it's going to be
somewhere over here in the wrong
direction okay
um so it's over here
now remember we know how to get from um
o to a by the way you might notice I
drew o in a totally different spot but
that's because when I'm doing a 2d
version of this
um it actually doesn't matter where I
Orient them I'm just drawing them in a
place that's convenient to me okay so
don't feel too bad about that right
I know how to get from o to a I know how
to get from A to B and what you know is
because just scrolling back this ratio
here right if if this part here is the
one and then I've got the two from the
orange components right can you tell me
what's the relationship between the
distance AP and the distance a b what's
that relationship
to two right it's it's the same as
internal division each component each
little section is the same right so
since those distances are the same
effectively what you've got is that a do
you agree a is just the midpoint between
B and P does that make sense right so we
now have two ways of going about this
right we can just say Okay um P it's
some arbitrary x y z right
you guys know how to find the midpoint
if you know the coordinates
um A and B and you say Okay midpoint a b
you just put the numbers in right um You
would say here's midpoint a b it would
be uh I'm just going to do it in um in
in as an order triple I would just go
and average all of the components do you
agree with that negative 3 plus 12
divided by two
um 10 plus 0 divided by two do you agree
with that like I I don't know what those
numbers are but I actually don't care
right now I can do same thing with a
it's just that I I've got an X comma
y comma Z right so this thing here this
is the answer to the midpoint right so
what I can say is that
um now let's so that I can write it all
out
I'll do it in yeah I'm still going to do
it as order triples because it's quite
it's quite wide across right it's going
to be x minus three on two that's my P
and my B right it's going to be uh y
plus 12 on 2 and then it's going to be
uh Z plus zero on two can you see me
doing the midpoint between p and and B
and then actually you know what I could
do it this way and make it even simpler
for you I know what that midpoint is
supposed to be equal to it's supposed to
be that thing is supposed to be two and
that thing is supposed to be negative
three and that thing is supposed to be
10. so all I've got is just three linear
equations and you just solve for x and y
and z independently okay so there's
solution method one however I I
acknowledge the fact that that's only
because we're in a one to two like that
gives you a midpoint okay let's suppose
it was not in a nice neat ratio where it
was one to one what's another way I
could do this I'm going to use my Vector
thinking right
um I know how to get to from o to B uh
let me move this out of the way sorry
Actually I don't even need this the
midpoint was just an illustration here
I know how to get from o to B like so I
know how to get from Ode to a and in the
previous question I also worked out how
to get from a
to B there's a b the vector okay can you
tell me what's the relationship between
this Vector a b which we worked out
before
and the vector a P it's going to the
left in this direction what's the
relationship between these two vectors
very good so same magnitude
but opposite direction right so all of
the numbers that we got for a b uh what
did we get for a b it's here isn't it
here's a b
so I'll just paste this here for
convenience and I'll make it an
appropriate color there we go if that's
a b then without any kind of extra
um like this is what's great about
Vector arithmetic right it kind of makes
a lot of things very simple all I have
to do is take the same magnitudes but
multiply them all by negative one that's
what gives me the opposite direction do
you agree so it's in this case five
negative 15 and then positive 10. is
that okay so in this case to get P I
just have to do
um op will be equal to First you go to a
and then you go to P I'm not even going
to do that arithmetic I trust you guys
you can do that arithmetic but isn't
that great as a as a way of thinking
about
um using your vector thinking to be able
to get to there okay
um I'm looking at the time I'm just
gonna do I'm not even going to work this
through but let's suppose let's change
this situation one more time
um this was externally
in the ratio
one to two Okay so we went over in this
Direction one and then we went to to get
back to B okay
um I wanted to change this a little tiny
bit
and I'm going to go and say what if we
did this externally
uh we did it internally in two to five
before now let's do it externally in two
to five I'm just gonna pause for a
minute I'm not going to talk this
through because I really want you to
have a go at this draw another interval
a b
and then I want you to think about where
where do you think P should be
um I'll give you a clue which is it's
roughly in the same direction as we've
drawn this but the the actual distances
the ratios are not going to be the same
because it's not one to two anymore it's
two to five so let me just pause for a
moment give you 60 seconds to draw and
have a think
yeah two to five two to five so that's
what we're gonna try
this is what I want us to try draw a new
a a new B well actually same coordinates
right but where do you think P would be
and um what I'm going to do is I'm
actually going to wait on you guys can
you just show each other once you have
gotten to the right spot and see if
you've got agreement and then when I see
you doing that that will be my
indication to show you my version okay
so let me just pause right there
just draw it don't even worry about
Computing it I just want you to yeah
situate where they are
have you got something drawn Ryan do you
have something interesting
um
so um that's fantastic obviously I can't
see your books because they're too far
away but I can hear your thinking which
is awesome so like you said right if I
position some a and sum B like so in
order to go sort of two hops away and
then five hops back right that means
that what you've got is remember when we
said before
um uh that two and five gives you seven
equal sections well in this case the two
is actually part of the five so here's
the two going away and then our five end
up being one two three four five so what
I've got here now is if I draw a line
all the way through
I've got five equal sections but
um these two go in the opposite
direction right so these are the as it
were the negative two and this orange
part is the positive five okay
now again we've got this point P here
right I already know how to get from o
to a I just need to get this AP vector
now the AP Vector I already know it's in
the opposite direction but the
magnitude's changed isn't it so what is
it in relation to a b
so
yeah fantastic negative two thirds so
this is a different scalar but the
negative captures the direction as in
it's the opposite direction and then the
two-thirds captures the fact that you
can you can literally see it can you see
how important a good diagram is right
this is literally two-thirds the
distance of this a b vector or wrong
color sorry this is the a b Vector
there's three parts there and there's
two parts on the other side so again you
can go ahead and compute that and find
out where P will be
yeah I think
yes
yeah
yeah and in fact I think this is one of
the situations where the formula
actually clouds what's going on and if
you just look at the diagram it tells
you um and so um if I haven't if you if
you're not sick of me doing this now um
you would definitely be sick of it by
the end of the topic draw draw and make
it a good size diagram because you can
see how much is going on like you need
to be able to put stuff labeling onto
there and it has to be good enough like
it doesn't have to be to scale but it
has to be good enough that you can do
some reasoning with the diagram okay
so I I'm gonna pause there um I'll hang
around till the Bell goes but
um when you have a look at I posted it
in the problem sets Channel when you
have a look at the assigned questions
within 5B they're not all about ratio
division um it's only the later
questions right
um but what happens is as you might have
noticed right we've been doing
multiplication and um subtraction and
um
addition just kind of along the way and
so the early questions in exercise 5B
kind of just sort of dip your toes in
the water and then the ratio division
questions combine all those different
skills together so draw a good diagram
for yourself and um yeah you should be
able to have no trouble with these um if
you want like I think one of the
questions in the exercise actually asks
you to prove the formula go ahead and do
it if you want it just adds more premium
rules in instead of fives and threes you
just get like K's and L's and that kind
of thing but um the diagram is always
going to be the key that's my um piece
of advice